where the hell are we
[Music]
what are we doing
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
what's up people I'm Dave Rubin this is
the Reuben report it is the last day of
May that's right it is May 31st in the
year 2023 we are live streaming on
Rumble locals and YouTube post game show
as always at
reubenreport.locals.com and I also post
some extra special stuff I've been
posting these videos did one this
morning just taking a walk with Clyde
sharing my morning thoughts asking for
your Insight on the show and I did read
some comments this morning that helped
me frame what we're going to do here
today uh before we get to it though I do
want to note because today is the last
day of May May 31st as you know tomorrow
begins pride month okay 30 days of
endless
rainbows it's not even the rainbow
anymore the rainbow everybody was okay
with the rainbow everybody used to love
the rainbow they've added these crazy
triangle and the brown and the pinks and
the Light blues they've ruined the
rainbow but the point is people we're
gonna have a very very gay month whether
you like it or not whether you're gay or
straight or whatever it's going to be a
very very gay month and what I would
recommend for you today is get out there
and do as many straight things as
possible because a lot of them are going
to be outlawed soon so if you're a if
you're a dude I want you to get out
there and bang a chick you know old
school and if you're a chick I want you
to get out there and find a dude okay
get out there do it and because next
week you could be literally taken to
prison if you do it where today is your
final day so get out there and do that
what are we doing on the program today
well uh as you guys know we've been
talking about it quite a bit the the
country seems to be drowning in this
nonsensical
never-ending evil corporate woke
propaganda nonsense and also uh
trillions of dollars of debt are we
going to reverse any of this stuff well
there are some signs actually that we
are reversing some of the woke stuff
right these boycotts against Bud Light
the boycott against Target now some
other companies it does seem like that
might have some results but when it
comes to the debt and the debt ceiling
and the never-ending printing of money
and the what seems to be an agreement
that the Republicans and Democrats now
have regarding the debt ceiling it seems
like it's just going to get worse and
worse but there is a way out and we are
going to try to take you there over the
next 47 minutes or so before we do that
let me talk to you guys about fast
growing trees you know you guys can
breathe some life into your own backyard
with
fastgrowingtrees.com this summer
from shade to fresh fruit to privacy and
natural beauty let fast growing
trees.com help you plant the dream
garden with your dream garden with their
expert advice and fast reliable shipping
fastgrowingtrees.com's plant experts
curate thousands of easy to grow plant
shrub and tree varieties for your unique
climate Meyer lemons to Evergreens and
everything in between no more waiting in
long lines and hauling heavy plants
around with fastgrowingtrees.com you
order online and your plants arrive at
your door in just a couple days I love
fast growing trees you know when we were
remodeling our home last summer we
bought a bunch of new trees thanks to
fast-growing trees we've got mangoes
back there and more I cannot recommend
them enough you guys and with fast
growing trees 30 day alive and Thrive
guarantee you know everything will look
great fresh out of the box join Over 1.5
million happy fast growing trees
customers go to
fastgrowingtrees.com Reuben right now to
get 15 off your entire order that's 15
off at fast growing trees dot com slash
Reuben okay so let's first start off oh
I should mention
the other big thing that happened
yesterday was that Trump went after
Kaylee in a crazy way you remember
Kaylee mcanany she's on Fox now but she
was Trump's press secretary the girl was
an absolute All-Star she was a hero of
Maga I don't know that there was anyone
ever more competent or more clean and
clear when it came to defending Trump
and his policies than this woman in that
freaking press uh you know room at the
White House where they were just going
after her relentlessly nobody I really
think this is true and I would love to
hear your opinion on this I don't think
anyone was a better explainer of his
ideas or his potential re-election or
whatever uh than Kaylee and he just went
after her yesterday and even the base is
not happy about this so we'll get to
that in just a second uh but let's start
with this boycott situation because Bud
Light is in a lot of trouble we covered
some of the numbers yesterday uh the the
company the parent company
Anheuser-Busch is losing a ton of market
value people are not buying Bud Light
it's starting to spread into some of
their other brands because obviously
Anheuser-Busch has many other beer
brands so that's spreading that we know
that this target boycott because of
marketing all of the lgbtq pride month
stuff to kids no one cares what adults
wear but when you are putting clothes
related to oh a little boy should tuck
his uh so it's you get it you get it
okay anyway Joe Rogan on his show was
talking about it with a couple comedians
some of his regulars Ari Shafer Mark
Normand and Shane Gillis they were sort
of saying that this is just going to be
like a temporary thing with Bud Light I
really think this thing is going to
stick that's what I've been saying I
don't think Bud Light is coming back
from this in any functional way anytime
soon Rogan seems to agree
it became a joke and that's tough to
overcome marketing wise it's tough to
get someone to order a Bud Light
publicly now that I know the joke you're
gonna get made fun of them it'll be
forgotten in a month no no two months
you'll make a joke on stage and be like
what no no no no you guys are crazy to
Bear dude you guys are crazy it's gonna
hang in there for a long time this is
going to be one of them cultural things
it's there's never been a brand that got
hit like this before this is a big deal
titty shots you think so they're gonna
get someone remember that lady saying
that we got to get away from the fratty
sense of humor inclusive yeah
definitely yeah yeah she's out
well they're gonna be fired and it's
real hard to argue with that one she
works at Comedy Central
together they're gonna get they'll be
saved this month every single company on
Earth is going to do like a commercial
all of them they've already done it
Miller Lite stuff they're all doing it
Ford Raptor did a gay commercial I saw
it right after yeah
all right so first you know on the gay
pride month situation first up I don't
think there should be a month for any of
these things I don't think there should
be a month for Gay Pride I don't think
there should be a black pride month or a
Jewish pride month or a white pride
month or any of these things you want a
day a day is fine a month is just
patently ridiculous but
I'm not obviously not against gay rights
or anything else there's no such thing
as gay rights we have individual rights
and everyone in this country who's
legally here should be treated the same
way under the law that goes without
saying I think these guys making the
point that there that it's about to just
go nuts with all the brands like we know
it's coming right we've shown you the
Bud Light stuff obviously we've shown
you the uh there was this Miller Lite
thing there was now the Ford Raptor like
it's just coming and coming and coming
and there's a funny joke there but let's
just let that be uh the point is it's
just not going to stop and we have to
just decide like what does how do you
react to companies that do this right
because again the t's are the problem
here not the individual T's who happen
to be adults dressing whoever they want
but the teas who are going after
children which in many cases will just
happen to be probably LG or B children
anyway it just does not stop Target
we've got some info here from the daily
wire Target donates to group that
promotes secret child gender transitions
lgbtq books in schools a little info on
that Target has repeatedly boasted about
efforts to support the gay lesbian and
straight education Network known as
glsen so they then put money into
pushing all of this gender ideology and
gender transitioning it what they call
gender affirming care which I often
point out is the least affirming thing
that you can do when you're chopping off
someone's genitals but it does not stop
and again this is all about kids it is
not about adults you know yesterday we
covered the story about how this Furry
Convention this group of people who put
on furry costumes whether they are
Pokemon and Charmander or just a wolf
and a bear and they go do whatever they
do with each other they were having this
convention in Florida and now because of
Ron DeSantis they've canceled the
convention and you might be like well
wait a minute why would Rhonda say I
just not want a bunch of adults to wear
furry costumes and chat with each other
well it has nothing to do with that it
has to do with he said you can't bring
kids to this hypersexual event and then
they decided to cancel the thing so
again this is all about children here's
an image from Barnes and Noble
Barnes and Noble this is from end
wokeness on Twitter Barnes and Noble
puts lgbtq books in front and center at
the kids section again there have always
been gay books they've always had
lesbian literature it's quite awful
they've always had all sorts of stuff
velvet rage and all of these things you
can read books about gay history and you
can read books about Oscar Wilde and
famous lesbians from your Ellen
DeGeneres's to Rosie O'Donnell's nobody
cares again why are you putting this
stuff to confuse children who may or may
not turn out to be gay or straight when
they are older but it doesn't just stop
with Barnes and Noble and Bud Light and
Target and Ford as we said just within
hours from now it's going to be gay
pride month and Adidas is in on it too
here's Adidas their pride swimsuit
and if you're not looking if you're not
seeing what we're showing you there you
may want to zoom in a little bit that
appears to be a man wearing a woman's
bathing suit and this has something to
do with pride so okay it's just not
gonna stop
here's another one from and wokeness
this one's not necessarily about gender
specifically but take a look at this one
uh you look like a Calvin Klein model
might be the worst thing to tell a woman
in 2023 so here's Calvin Klein ads okay
so now we've shifted from the gender
stuff there's this other thing where
they're really pushing they want uh
overweight or fat or obese people to be
seen and everything I'm not against
overweight or fat people everyone should
try to take care of themselves
accordingly I suppose we could all lose
a couple off the midsection
but why are they pushing this I thought
it would be interesting if we contrasted
that with old school Calvin Klein you
remember this this is from when I was a
kid this is probably from what what year
was that from probably about 92 94 or
something around there that's Mark
Wahlberg and and Kate Moss now you might
say she's too thin and you might say no
guy can look like him that's fine but
which one should advertising is about
aspiring to something right which should
you aspire to to look like right
relatively fit people even if she was a
little thin or should we all look like
obese people there's there's a problem
there's a problem here in society and
guess what it's not just that they want
people to dress up like animals with
these furry conventions now they want
the dogs to be gay too here's Pet Smart
that's right show your pride if your
cat's not a lesbian
why do so many lesbians have cats
we should be doing a show about that
that's an interesting that would be far
more interesting what you could have is
a therapist sitting at PetSmart sitting
there going oh I see you're in the cat
section tell me about your lesbianism
that would be interesting to me but just
putting cats and dogs in rainbow colored
things it's so nonsensical Clyde is
downstairs I have every reason to
believe that Clyde everything being
equal you know he's been they did
whatever they chopped his nuts off but I
think that Clyde if he had his nuts
would would be into girl dogs but either
way why would I be putting him in
and now here's the here's the this is
the sauce on top of this horrific
sandwich we're eating Chick-fil-A guys
they're going woke too but this one is
just incredible here better at together
we are better one of our core values at
Chick-fil-A means when we combine our
unique backgrounds and experiences with
a culture of belonging we can strengthen
the quality of care we deliver
Chick-fil-A's commitment to being better
at together means embedding diversity
equity and inclusion into everything we
do is that not completely insane how
many times do we have to go through this
if you sell a chicken sandwich
if you sell a water glass whatever you
do that should be the only thing you're
focusing on right we really focus we
really talked about this yesterday once
you let diversity equity and inclusion
in you will destroy the product and
congratulations now even Chick-fil-A you
have been infected you you have been
infected and it just who cares how many
people you have making chicken
sandwiches who are black lesbians who
cares how many people you have making
counting your sauce packets and whether
what their sexuality is nobody cares but
congratulations it's now in your system
and it'll take out Chick-fil-A too mark
my words but all of that is crazy enough
it is also affecting Sports as you know
this one is is so crazy well but
nothing's too crazy right so nothing is
too crazy uh there is a relief pitcher
on the Toronto Blue Jays uh by the name
of Anthony any bass now he liked a video
all he did was like a video of a pastor
explaining why he felt that boycotting
Target was legit a pastor so just
remember he didn't post anything himself
Anthony bass he just liked the video of
a pastor explaining why the boycotting
of Target related to going after kids
was a good thing well the Toronto Blue
Jays caught wind of this no doubt
activists saw that and bumped it up to
the Toronto Blue Jays and here is the
struggle session apology they choked out
of this guy yesterday this is this is
actually depressing watch this
I recognized yesterday I made a post
that was hurtful to the pride Community
which includes friends of mine and close
family members of mine and I am truly
sorry for that
I just spoke with my teammates and
shared within my actions yesterday I
apologize with them and as right now I'm
using the Blue Jays resources to better
educate myself to make better decisions
moving forward the ballpark is for
everybody we include all fans at the
Ballpark and we want to welcome
everybody that's all I have to say thank
you depressing that's all I have to say
after all of these years where we've all
seen the lessons of what happens when
you apologize especially when you
apologize unjustly everyone has
apologized and it is worthy of
apologizing when an apology is true when
when an apology is virtuous but the way
he has to choke out that statement
nobody he wasn't saying that gay people
shouldn't come to baseball games he was
liking a post that was from a pastor
going saying hey corporations maybe you
shouldn't push gender transition
clothing on children
but congratulations he's had his Mao
style struggle session and then I saw
that the manager of the Toronto Blue
Jays his last name what's his name is
Schneider is his last name uh he
basically was like well this is just the
beginning of his apology we'll keep
going with it there is never enough that
will guy that guy will have to live on
his knees forever gay joke there but
we'll let it be it's just not gonna stop
and I and I am so it's so Twisted but I
you have to just wonder like what
pressure was brought to bear I actually
don't mean this to attack uh bass right
like he was whether it was the managers
the management whether it was his agents
whether it was the entire MLB
organization pressure was brought to
bear on him that he had to issue that
apology and he did it in the most
forthright way possible but it's like
that that's not true that's not true
what you just did right there and it's
not good for the direction that Society
is taking but it isn't just that the
woke virus is going after our massive
corporations it's leaking into I would
say conservative
institutions much like the National
Review we'll get to that in just a
moment let's talk about Black Forest
first guys
nmn or nicotine nicotamide monocleotide
how do I do there pretty good I think is
a precursor to NAD plus and has been
shown to provide numerous health
benefits such as improved energy weight
management endurance strength and even
anti-aging by potentially reclassifying
nmn as a drug the FDA is restricting
access to a supplement that could
significantly improve people's lives the
government via the FDA is providing
pharmaceutical Giants a chance to
monopolize it this strategy isn't driven
by concerns over the efficacy or safety
of nmn but rather a power play to Corner
the market and remove your supplement
from your reach with the threat of nmn
sales stopping abruptly now is the time
to secure secure your supply by taking
Black Forest m n and Supply supplement
as a daily user of the Black Forest mnn
1000 milligram supplement I've
personally experienced a remarkable
boost in my energy levels mental Clarity
and overall well-being trust me guys
once you start using this supplement
you'll wonder how you ever manage
without it Black Forest nmn is available
for purchase and you can even get a 10
discount using Code Dave at the link
below stand up uh for your right to make
decisions over your own health and
resist the government's attempt to limit
our choices be sure to check the pin
comment and description for the link and
discount code mentioned in this video
Stay empowered stay informed and don't
let the government dictate what's best
for your health and now back to me okay
should we continue with a little bit
more of what the corporations are doing
before we move on here's Kohl's baby
collection take a look
yeah again these are marketed towards
children
the question is why are you trying to
confuse children with things a shirt a
shirt that's for an adult or even for a
kid that just says happy Pride
okay fine uh it's this stuff where
they're confusing this new Trans flag
everything has to be biracial and
there's someone in a wheelchair it's all
just too confusing and it is not what
should be going on in a child's mind but
I mentioned that this stuff has been
leaking into even conservative Outlets
so let's put that image up one more time
again
real quick so the end wokeness again
they put this up put this up about coals
still selling their baby collection on
their website then Philip Klein who's
the editor of National Review National
Review used to be I would say a fairly
standard uh conservative mainstream
conservative Outlet this guy's the
editor there here's what he said I don't
have a problem with this if somebody
wants to dress their baby in a pride
onesie why should it matter we're not
talking about transitioning minors here
it's just a shirt
now the problem is that's not quite
right now I don't have a problem with
someone putting their kid in a onesie
that has whatever they want to have on
it except that this this Pride logo this
lgbtq logo not just the rainbow flag
that that for a long time just stood for
equality and that was it this new thing
with the triangle and the trans thing
again it is actively not only attacking
the gays because they're trying to
transition Young gays they're trying to
tell young girls that they're actually
boys and young boys that they're
actually girls so it's rapidly anti-gay
but it's also rapidly anti-strike right
because then they want these biological
boys to basically kick the crap out of
girls in sports so this is a really
bizarre position for a conservative to
take what are you conserving if you're
always letting them move on reality uh
and here's a headline from National
Review I believe this was written oh
yeah it was written by the editor Philip
Klein some sometimes a onesie is just
the onesie it's also interesting leave
this up for just a sec it's also
interesting
that they're marketing it with this
appears to be I guess a largely black
family again there's somebody in a
wheelchair there like they are trying
this is what intersectionality is all
about they are really trying to take all
of these perceived oppressions and
combine them so that these people will
basically think that their sexuality or
their skin color is a political ideology
and you really need to understand that
that's why I have nothing to do with the
LGBT community okay I really have
nothing to do with it
um and I don't want anything to do with
it being gay is a sexuality okay being
trans is a is a sexual identity okay
those are different than political
ideologies and if you think that your
political ideology what you think of how
the world should be organized how
Society should be organized if you think
that that is deeply connected to your
sexuality or your skin color you look at
your hand and go oh my God I must think
this about taxes and foreign policy you
were really confused about things but I
would say one of the reasons that people
are confused about things it's not just
because we've had this endless culture
War it's also because our politicians
haven't been that great to say the least
every now and again we get some of all
stars but mostly we're working with you
know like the 12th man uh so here's
Kevin McCarthy now I happen to
personally like Kevin McCarthy I've
interviewed him several times you know
just what two two or three months ago we
were down in DC or up in DC I'm in
Florida now we were up in DC uh
interviewing Kevin McCarthy at the
Capitol I think he's done some good
things as leader already you know he cut
the funding to the 87 000 IRS agents
he's tightened the strings on certain
things but now this debt ceiling deal is
coming through uh and he's trying to
sell it to the American people and and
it's not looking that great here's
here's his take on it before I
editorialize more than that
weeks of negotiations we have come to an
agreement in principle we still have a
lot of work to do but I believe this is
an agreement in principle that's worthy
of the American people
it has historic reductions in spending
consequential reforms that will lift
people out of poverty into the workforce
reign in government overreach there are
no new taxes no new government programs
there's a lot more within the bill we
still have more work to do tonight to
finish all the writing of it
okay so now you guys remember when Kevin
was going up when McCarthy was going up
to become speaker their house and you
remember the five or six days of endless
fighting and the 14 votes it took and
that there were the more they would say
radical side of the Republican Party the
people who wanted more concessions out
of him so that there wouldn't be more
spending and they would have more
oversight on where money was going and
the types of things that government was
going to do and what the Republican
Party would sign on to they were all
framed as right wing
radicals and maniacs and everything else
one of those guys was Chip Roy now the
same uh trip that I went to DC and
interviewed Kevin McCarthy the very next
day I interviewed chip Roy alongside uh
Thomas Massey this is from I would say
the more freedom Wing the more
libertarian-ish wing of the Republican
Party who really are concerned about the
fiscal issues and got major concessions
out of McCarthy so you heard what
McCarthy said right there about the deal
here is what chip Roy tweeted it's a
it's a little Twitter thread for you he
said thread there are members of the GOP
claiming Democrats got nothing from the
deal oh really one an uncapped debt
ceiling with an expiration date worth
approximately 4 trillion two basically
no cuts a freeze uploaded 2023 spending
level three zero clawback of the 1.2
trillion inflation reduction act crony
giveaways to Elite leftists for grid
destroying unriable energy four 98 of
the IRS expansion left fully in place
five no work requirements for Medicaid
and only eight and only age adjustments
for TANF and snap six no rains act
statutory requirement for Congress to
approve approve huge regulations just an
administrative pay go that the
administration will get to enforce seven
no border security and a deal allowing
them to avoid policy riders in the fall
okay so a fight is a Bruin
as they say here in the Republican party
and I think it is a good fight to have
you may remember and I would welcome you
to go back to our videos when the fight
was a bruin for those four or five days
against McCarthy I kept saying that it
was good mainstream media was framing it
as oh my God the Republican party is
falling out blah blah no no it was good
because you have people with that are in
the same political party fighting for
what they believe in now it seems to me
that this is not a good deal that
McCarthy is just giving up a little bit
too easily which was the the fear about
McCarthy now remember
Donald Trump supported McCarthy again I
personally like McCarthy and I think
he's done some good things you know I
mentioned right before I read the chip
statement uh that he cut all of the
funding to the 87
000 IRS agents it sounds like it's not
going to be all of the funding that's
cut so and also a lot of when you say
going back to spending levels well it's
because our spending levels were so
insane during covid so just going back
to levels that already were inflated
like that's a little bit of linguistic
trickery right there anyway there are
several other Republicans who are not
happy with Kevin McCarthy uh we've got a
compilation here this is from CNN uh
we'll start with Republican Dan Bishop
then there's some from Chip Roy and some
other people take a look
how much I mean how much confidence do
you have in the speaker right now nine
zero
what basis is there for confidence you
cannot forfeit the tool of Republican
Unity it was not necessary to do the
speaker lying about the way he's
characterizing this Bill yes he's lied
but the bill is chock full of things
that are that are cosmetic and
artificial that have the same exact
effect McCarthy has lost some trust in
how this has been handled what I said
was we got to re-look at how our
leadership structure is in place
something like that on Glenn show
because we can't do what we're doing
right now
um we were being very successful for
five months this was a mistake we
abandoned the structure that was making
us successful so we're gonna have to
rethink it all what was emphatically
clear in all of our conversations in
January was that we would be reporting
things out of the rules committee
unanimously and right now that is in
jeopardy
okay so these guys have some leverage
because of the concessions that they got
out of McCarthy those five months ago
the question here really is what is
McCarthy's game is he just kind of going
all in on the swamp was this really the
best deal that he could do is he
thinking about it see one of the
problems here is that no you know this
because of the way the mainstream media
is in bed with the Democrats no matter
what happens Republicans get blamed and
I sense that that probably is what
McCarthy fears he fears okay if we don't
increase the debt ceiling let's say we
do what we think is right we completely
are not going to vote for this America
goes into default it potentially leads
us to a recession right like that's
that's just reality his feeling is oh I
suspect his feeling I can't speak for
him but I suspect his private feeling
would be oh we would have done the right
thing not given the Democrats what they
want we'd have a temporary pain point
with the recession but the people will
all blame us because of the the
coordination between the Democrats and
the mainstream media the people all they
must and then when we're in a recession
and P and you know gas prices are up
again and the supply chain is struggling
again and groceries cost more everyone
will blame us and that will be bad for
us in the long term so I think he's
playing more of a political game which
is part of the problem of politics it's
always about politics that's a bit of a
problem and the guys who were standing
up against him they're playing I think
what what I would say is a little bit
more of a principled game
and it's for all of you to decide like
which side of that you want to fall on
uh but he McCarthy does seem to be
shrinking at the moment and the question
is so what leadership do we need right
like what is the energy we need to get
out of this situation where we always
end up spending more and no matter what
happens the debt ceiling raises and we
continue to be a debtor nation and we
all know that none of us could live our
lives like this if you have a credit
card and you have a ten thousand dollar
limit and you hit ten thousand dollars
they don't let you charge any more money
until you pay some of it down but what
we do is somehow always increase it oh
it's 12 000 this month 14 000 this month
next year it's 20. and then we will just
owe all of our money
to China we will just owe them a
ton of money and then one day they might
call in for the bill they might be like
you know what we've had enough of this
and then on that day you know what
happens we better thank God that we've
got more weapons than they do because
that's ultimately how it works right
it's a mafia game at some point you
borrow some money from the mafia knowing
that if you don't pay them back in time
they're going to break your legs but if
you have more weapons than they do so
that's really what's going on here so
what is the bar we should set what what
is the strategy that we should have
maybe it is time for someone like
McCarthy or someone that could
potentially be more influential than
McCarthy to say enough is enough we will
have to deal with some temporary pain
but we will do the right thing here's
Governor Ron DeSantis in Iowa yesterday
discussing the cowardice of D.C
Republicans and what the Fallout is
going to be because of this deal
we now see Washington has now cooked up
their latest quote debt deal and I can
tell you this our nation was careening
towards bankruptcy before the debt deal
and it will still be careening towards
bankruptcy after this debt deal this is
green lighting four trillion dollars in
new debt in less than two years it took
us almost 200 years to get to 4 trillion
in debt in the first place it locks in
inflated covid level uh era levels of
spending and it keeps 98 percent of the
000 new IRS agents that Joe Biden
instituted this
solve our nation
we have a 1.2 trillion dollar GDP in
Florida we'd be the 13th largest economy
in the world if we were our separate
country and yet with 1.2 trillion
economy our state debt is only 17
billion dollars
okay you really need to understand the
numbers there right so we have an
incredible GDP here in Florida we have
low debt related to that and what that
then allows is for economic growth and
when you have economic growth and more
people start doing what they want to do
and it actually becomes I would say
spiritual and cultural in nature when
the government has gotten out of your
way because it is acted uh trimly and
effectively you can then do what you
want to do build the type of life that
you want to live and I'm pretty sure
that is the whole point of of the whole
freaking thing it has something to do
with that
um so DeSantis is right he's now now
obviously he's striking the tone that
chip Roy is striking and he's going
directly after McCarthy so here you go
again if you're a trump supporter right
now you really have to think about this
and again I say this to someone I
personally like McCarthy and I'm trying
to give him a bit of leeway here
I think I think I gave the devil his due
when I was explaining what his position
might be
um but DeSantis is basically saying we
cannot do this anymore now the what you
might think is well wait a minute they
always say it they always say it except
tell me you watching this right now tell
me in the comment section tell me in the
post game show what name one thing that
DeSantis said he was going to do that he
has not done
he has gone out there and set an agenda
and consistently done all of those
things so what he's telling you right
there and there's every reason to
believe him is this is not how we will
behave if I am president now the
president obviously is not in charge of
the budget Congress is in charge of the
budget but if we elect a president
who does what he says he's going to do
sets out the agenda right he becomes the
leader of the party and then the leader
of the country and then by extension the
leader of the Free World you might have
a whole bunch of people who follow along
with that and start doing the right
thing that's what real leadership is all
about DeSantis talked a bit more about
leadership
at the end of the day leadership is not
about entertainment it's not about
building a brand it's not about virtue
signaling it is about results and in
Florida we didn't lead with merely words
we followed up our words with deeds and
we have produced a record of
accomplishment that we would put up
against anybody in this country again he
has done what he said he was going to do
it and as you know the the votes then
showed that people actually appreciate
that so let's contrast that with what
Donald Trump has been up to so DeSantis
is out there in Iowa with the people
right now his wife is out there the team
is out there they're on the ground Trump
has been golfing and of course he's also
been on Truth social here's what he put
up yesterday I'm gonna have to
take a deep breath for this one uh
Kaylee milk toast mcanany just gave out
the wrong poll numbers on Fox news I am
34 points up on De sanctimonious not 25
up while 25 is great it's not 34. she
knew the number was corrected upwards by
the group that did the poll the rhinos
and globalists can have her Fox News
should only use real stars okay now
first off
uh this is what he's doing this is what
he's doing he is going after let's put
aside let's put aside who's right or
wrong about the polls uh actually the
the poll that she was referencing uh she
did not lie about the numbers but let's
just completely put that aside for a
second and let's even I'll even Grant
Trump she completely lied let this just
say she completely lied and she's owned
by the rhinos and the globalist right
everyone's owned by the rhinos and the
globalist except for you and that you
keep hiring people and then firing
people who are also owned by the Rhinos
in the globe okay fine let's go with
that if he was he was watching Fox News
so he's spending all day on true social
and he's spending all day golfing and
watching Fox News okay the Santa is out
there actually campaigning and trying to
convince people that he has a better
vision for the country but okay you're
doing all that if you saw that now Kaley
has been your biggest Defender I don't
think there was anyone that was
associated with Trump over the course of
that presidency that was more consistent
more classy more forthright more of a
true Fighter for your ideas for your
campaign for all of it during covet
against a crazily Radical leftist Media
trying to lie about you all the time she
was the gold standard so maybe you would
send her a text and say Kaylee you know
I think you screwed up the numbers could
you could you issue a correction when
you're on TV tomorrow could you maybe
put out a tweet or could you explain to
me what those numbers are again it does
not even matter what the truth is I'm
talking about a level of behavior here
but that's obviously not how he operates
and it seems to be careening out of
control and actually I did see something
a little bit different
the reaction online for the last day or
so has been a little bit different you
know when Trump trashes you know he
trashes everybody he's ever worked with
right John Bolton Chris Christie Mike
Pence everyone that he's ever hired
Chris Ray is an idiot and a traitor and
a rhino and a globalist everybody
everybody right eventually he'll turn on
Donald Trump and he'll say that guy was
an idiot and a rhino or globalist too
like okay fine and the audience or the
the the base of the bass and I'm not
talking about the person watching this
and I'm actually not talking about most
Trump supporters I think most Trump
supporters are waking up to what's going
on and seeing that there's a better
choice right now I believe that maybe
I'm wrong in the end of the day but I I
do think that that's happening and I
think the polls will be reflecting that
soon enough
but the base of the base that that
supports him no matter what the people
as he says I could go out there and
shoot somebody on Fifth Avenue and they
would still support me I think even they
were seeing him going after Kaylee and
being like this is this is a bridge too
far so there's a litany a never-ending
Trove of videos that I could have shown
you of her defending Trump in the in the
Viper's Nest we found this one defending
Trump as press secretary and just note
that this is the woman that he has now
turned on
does the president denounce white
supremacism and groups that espoused it
in all their forms this has been
answered Yesterday by the president
himself the day before by the president
himself on the debate stage the
president was asked this he said sure
three times yesterday he was point blank
blank asked do you uh denounce white
supremacy and he said I've always
denounced any form of that I can go back
and read for you in August 2019 and one
voice our nation must condemn racism
bigotry and white supremacy in August of
2017 which is really record it really is
mixed it has conducted at times he said
he didn't want to acknowledge it or
address it his record is very mixed
record is not mixed in the slightest and
when you go back in history you can see
that history right here when you go back
down the street you can see that
Japanese Jackson it kind of praise the
president as someone who served under
served communities this president with
Mar-A-Lago it was the first Palm Beach
Club open to African Americans and Jews
and in fact
on the issue
what is this white house
it I have his record right here and you
need to let me finish because the record
is quite funny that the media goes
Haywire about interrupting and debates
and then chooses to pursue that very
same tactic themselves this is a White
House briefing you ask a question and
you give me time to answer man how
freaking great was she
I have no doubt you were having the same
feeling I was having watching that man
how great was she an incredible
Communicator a fighter I think you could
argue she was defending Trump in a
better way than he could even defend
himself and that is who he has now
decided to throw under the bus and is
now just like Ronda Santos a rhino and a
globalist and a Fox News Lackey and blah
blah blah enough enough is enough and I
think more and more people are starting
to see it I really do that is not
leadership
that is not leadership it cannot be that
this man is basically uh political Jesus
who has no flaws and everyone around him
is an effing idiot because then I guess
the flaw would be in him for surrounding
himself with these people but Kaylee let
me just say something else about Kaylee
you know I I know her a little bit
outside of the cameras and all that
stuff we've done Gutfeld a couple times
together some other shows at Fox and and
met a few times she is just like
absolutely lovely and nice and she's not
a rhino or a globalist or a sellout or a
shill or any of those things she's just
like a really sweet person who deeply
cares about her family and the country
what Rings true to you is it that or is
it what Trump is saying about here about
her so we have we have to decide now
guys like which way do we want this the
Republican party to go and by extension
which way do we want the country to go
I'm not sitting here having to waste any
time talking about the Democrats or the
left or the left today I think there is
a wide tent freedom already developing
right now obviously DeSantis is the best
guy for that and if Trump can just let
go of the ego I think we could have a
Reagan re-election style Landslide right
now that's the healing moment for all of
us oh America wide tent Freedom it all
still works and we can still have it
here's DeSantis on that wide tent
I can tell you that the parents in the
State of Florida were very happy that we
took those stands uh the media was not
happy about that the left was not happy
about that and there was a little
business that you may have heard of in
Florida that also wasn't happy about
that named Disney
and people told me they said listen the
media is coming after you the left but
if Disney weighs in they're the 800
pound gorilla you better watch out
they're gonna steamroll you well here I
stand
I'm not backing down one inch
we run the state of Florida
they do not run the State of Florida I
know all these Republicans are lining up
against me to take the side of Disney
but I'll tell you this we stand for the
protection of our children we will fight
those who seek to Rob them of their
innocence and on that point there will
be no compromise
[Applause]
I mean that brings us full circle full
circle guys like on that point there
will be no compromise stop going after
the kids stop having corporations push
all of this crap down our throats and
then at the political level like maybe
stop with the games is it look obviously
I happen to like DeSantis I happen to
think he is the right guy like my cards
are shown right you can look at them
they're on the table right here right my
life is better I brought two different
companies here I brought all these
people here everything's working here
that is obvious but if you're still in
the Trump camp like think think for a
second is what you want is it true that
now Kaylee is also a rhino and a
globalist just like everybody else is
Donald Trump the only person on the
planet who knows what the truth is and
even though he keeps hiring all the
wrong people because eventually he has
to turn on them and Destroy them he will
also be the one that will be our
Redemption or is it possible
that he's just holding on now and
there's not much more to hold on to and
there is a better choice that is what is
laid out in front of us I think the more
people get to know DeSantis and see
DeSantis and see the competency and see
that there are no leaks that he doesn't
turn on everyone around him that Florida
is flourishing in the in the very
obvious ways and that's what could be
exported and that it doesn't have to be
like this and we could have a great
American comeback I think it's all going
to start to work but you know maybe I'm
wrong but maybe not we shall see if you
want to join us for the post game show
please do by going to a Reuben report
dot locals.com right now we leave you
with a quick Chick-fil-A style cold
clothes I'll see everybody on the other
side
oh no
[Laughter]
[Music]
thank you